Louis surly has authored a new book
about Vietnam and general Creighton
Abrams
it's called Vietnam Chronicles the
Abrams tapes 1968 to 1972 he talks about
that now at the National Archives in
Washington this lasts about an hour good
evening ladies and gentlemen and welcome
to the National Archives my name is Sam
Anthony and I am your host for tonight's
lecture on book signing it is a pleasure
to welcome you to this evening's program
and to welcome back to the National
Archives dr. lewis sorely as he will
discuss his book the Vietnam Chronicles
the Abrams tapes 1968 to 1972 a few
points before we begin copies of the
book are available for sale outside in
the theater lobby following our book
signing tonight our lecture tonight we
will have a book signing if you are new
to the National Archives I'd like to
welcome you to our beautiful new William
G McGowan theater this is part of our
latest renovation of the National
Archives over the past three years the
National Archives has renovated this
facility and the results are a newly
designed and upgraded rotunda where you
can view the charge of freedom including
the declaration the Constitution in the
Bill of Rights on a series of conference
rooms and this new theater where we can
hold lectures book signings performances
as well as film festivals the new
Lawrence F O'Brien special exhibits
gallery where we hold exhibits as well
as the new permanent exhibit gallery we
call the public vaults these are all
free they're open to the public and if
you'd like to learn more about these
programs please go to our website
archives gov tonight I'd like to welcome
book TV to tonight's presentation and in
our print programs tonight you will find
a biographical sketch in your program of
dr. shirley so i will just mention
briefly that he is a third-generation
graduate of West Point who also holds a
PhD from the Johns Hopkins University he
devoted over three decades to public
service first as an armor officer in the
United States Army then as a civilian
official in the Central Intelligence
Agency he will speak to us about his new
book Vietnam Chronicles subtitled the
abrams tapes 1968 to 1972
just published by Texas Tech University
Press after his remarks there will be
time for questions and discussion and
then the author will be available to
sign copies of his book outside the
theater in our lobby would you please
welcome dr. Lewis Orly
I began by saying how much I appreciate
the privilege of this forum and this is
a beautiful new theater SM I certainly
have to agree warmest thanks for
inviting me and to all of you for coming
especially on this a wintry wet night
this evening I'm going to tell you
something about this book it's my fourth
book having to do in whole or in major
part with war Vietnam a topic that
continues to fascinate me in a number of
ways but Vietnam monocles is quite
different from the other books I think
it is something unique in the field of
military history a work of a kind we
have never had before and may never have
again that is because it is based on
tape recordings made in the saigon
headquarters of general Creighton Abrams
during the years he commanded American
forces in the Vietnam War we are thus
enabled to listen in on periodic
councils of war and on the briefings and
discussions that took place when
high-level visitors came to Vietnam it
is as though in an earlier era we had
listened in as Napoleon and his marshals
plot of their strategy or when George
Washington and his generals laid plans
for battles of the Revolutionary War
when general Abrams returned home in the
summer of 1972
to become the Army's chief of staff he
brought with him certain highly
classified materials relating to his
service in Vietnam when in the autumn of
1974 Abrams died in office his successor
ordered these materials to be
sequestered with both their existence
and location classified top-secret
eventually however I learned of these
materials from sources in the Army
hierarchy who were friendly to my work
and eventually I was granted access to
them the heart of inflexion turned out
to be 455 tape recordings made over the
for years it took me almost exactly a
year of weekdays to listen to the tapes
containing an estimated 2,000 hours of
recorded materials and make
transcriptions of selected portions
since this work was conducted in a
secured area of vault at Carlisle
barracks I was not able to take a
computer or a recorder along thus over
the year
I made nearly 3200 pages of single
spaced handwritten notes on three-ring
notebook paper and most of them are
verbatim records of what was on the
tapes when these notes had been cleared
and I was able to enter them in my
computer
they ran to eight hundred thirty five
thousand words of that I have selected
four hundred fifty thousand words for
inclusion in Vietnam chronicles
constituting what I believe to be the
most excellent and interesting and in
some cases funny material on the tapes
as everyone here knows the historical
record of the Vietnam War is very rich
presenting a formidable challenge to any
historian who aspires to gain
comprehensive knowledge much less
understanding of such a long and complex
complex conflict much of it is found in
archival materials messages orders
assessments captured documents media
accounts much more continues to be built
up as the papers of individual
participants become available to
researchers oral histories provide very
useful individual accounts in the voice
of the respondent but only on these
tapes do we get to hear senior
participants and their supporting staffs
interact on a continuing basis as they
seek to deal with the challenges of the
war in its every aspect the people on
the tapes are wonderful collection
fascinating personalities many of them
larger than life Creighton Abrams
Ellsworth bunker bill Colby Earl wheeler
Mel Laird Stanley Resort john mccain tom
moore fred wand
Sir Robert Thompson plus a collection of
usually anonymous and often brilliant
briefers and analysts and the topics
with with which they wrestle are equally
interesting in the aggregate a diverse
and comprehensive composite of the war
in all its aspects
thus a number of inversing stories run
through the tapes and the years they
reflect these include changes in concept
of the nature of the war and of strategy
and tactics for contact development of
South Vietnam's
armed forces the pacification program
and neutralization of the enemy
infrastructure amongst the rural
populace progressive withdrawal of
American forces intelligence
breakthroughs in monitoring infiltration
down the Ho Chi Minh Trail interdiction
of traffic on that trail combat
incursions into Cambodia and Laos major
battles culminating in the 1972 Easter
offensive land reform ennemy adaptations
to changes in their battlefield fortunes
maturation of South Vietnam's leadership
resumption of the air campaign against
North Vietnam political military
relations in Washington as they spilled
over onto American leaders in Saigon
increasingly difficult budget strictures
the impact of negotiations in Paris on
conduct of the war and of course the
interplay of colorful and sometimes
volatile personalities among both
Americans and Vietnamese involved in
conduct of the war in short the tapes
reveal new secrets resolve old arguments
and provide fresh insights into the
latter years of America's longest war
significantly there is on the tapes
absolutely no criticism criticism or
second-guessing of their predecessors
with a conspicuous conception of Robert
Palmer
they cut him up on every opportunity
even years after his early departure
from Vietnam their greatest disdain is
reserved for the met the press and the
media in general a few days ago I noted
online that the books barnes and noble
sales rank was 54,000 147 and on Amazon
it was at one hundred two thousand five
hundred eight I was a little
disappointed by that since I know my
sister personally bought three copies
but then I saw that on Amazon I am NOT
making this up
they are offering a package deal Vietnam
Chronicles along with eats shoots leaves
the zero tolerance approach to
punctuation for one low price I I am
confident that promotion will boost
sales dramatically the book weighs more
than three pounds and runs to over nine
hundred pages so unless you want to stay
here fairly late into the night
all I'm going to be able to do is give
you some of the flavor while also
leaving time for discussion I have
chosen for that purpose a handful of
topic areas I'll call them chunks that I
believe you will find of interest and in
addition I have two brief sidebars
before launching into those I should
also mention that for this family
ordinance in some spots I'll be cleaning
up the language a little if you want the
unexpurgated version I guess you'll just
have to buy the book chunk one has to do
with intelligence and I've chosen that
first because it is so important to all
else that that permeates the discussions
of these years Major General later
Lieutenant General Philip Davidson had
the interesting experience of being the
Mack Vijay to the intelligence officer
during the last year General William C
Westmoreland command American poisons
forces in Vietnam then continuing in
that post for the first year General
Avery was in command Davidson was thus
in a position to offer some interesting
comparative insights into the importance
accorded
intelligence and its use in the early
and later periods of American
involvement general Abrams took command
formally in June of 1968 in October of
that year general Davidson told a
high-level visitor
I think the intelligence is many times
better than it was six months ago he
attributed this to several factors in
the first place the breakthrough that we
got on infiltration gave us a great lead
on the enemy we never had before there
he was referring to an extremely
important development in signals
intelligence the newly acquired ability
to intercept and decrypt to decrypt
message traffic detailing enemy
movements down the Ho Chi Minh Trail so
that as general Abrams once remarked
they could arrange a proper reception
for them and said Davidson for the first
time there are agents placed in the
right places for the first time their
agents placed in the right places and
they are giving invaluable information I
think our analytic capability has
increased immeasurably over the last few
months and the benefits he said of
McVie's computer capability were just
beginning to be felt a couple of weeks
later Davidson told a regional
conference on intelligence collection
the commander is pleased with his
intelligence acts on it and has forced
the staff to act upon it that is what
has changed in the last four or five
months I think Davidson continued
unquestionably one of the things that's
caused success is communications
intelligence perhaps the biggest but
also I think the most dramatic proof has
been the breakthrough in the high-level
agents the Qazvin guide the a.22 these
are designators super spook 2324 the
guys that are really giving it to you
the way it is you don't have to say gee
I wonder if this is right or not you
know that guy is telling the truth
someone commented that's something
Arvin's done arming the revoir me of the
Republic of Vietnam to which Davidson
responded that is an Irvine contribution
first-rate you're right
the crucial importance of intelligence
as viewed by general Abrams was
articulated when General Charles bull
steel then commanding US forces in Korea
visited Saigon lone still asked
regarding intelligence which is what
half the game over here Abrams well
sometimes I get it up around 90% but
I've never gotten below 50% this is your
life's blood it is your life's blood
when I look back on my service and
especially my times in the Pentagon I
wish I had seen this as clearly and I
regret it but added Abrams I think the
Intelligence Corps the branch and the
quality has really been functioning
we're getting some fine time another
place that I think they're strong there
are some warrant officers in these radio
research units that are really
first-class professionals been at it a
long time and they're dedicated to it
and he said the field meaning the unit's
deployed deployed in the field the field
is far more up on the step on
intelligence than they were then
meaning in 1967 when he first arrived
far more in a session with his senior
subordinate commanders Abrams stressed
that everything good that happened seems
to come from good intelligence and a lot
of this galloping around produces
nothing because the intelligence is
lacking and in a conference with Gerald
Calvin Vienna chief of the Vietnamese
rank General Staff Abrams said of the
application of airpower
I think the targeting keeps improving
that's very important if the targeting
is of good quality then it lands on the
enemy or his supplies not good to land
in the jungle you know nothing but
monkeys and elephants that's all
intelligence it's the only way now
you'll see that Fermi permeate the other
things I'm going to talk about it most
of them chunk to I want to say something
about the nature of the war because the
way in which general Abrams and his
principal associates viewed the war was
radically different than how it had been
viewed by under his predecessor a bruise
and Ellsworth marker and William Colby
all pronounce this one war in which
combat operations improvement of South
Vietnamese military forces and
pacification were of equal importance
and priority those three things during
the earlier period that emphasis had
been almost exclusively on large-scale
combat operations intended to inflict
crippling casualties on the enemy on the
premise that that would eventually cause
him to lose art and cease aggression
against the south they were successful
in an imposing an enormous tragic
casualties but the desired outcome did
not result the first time melvin laird
visited saigon as the new secretary of
defense which took place in March of
1969 ambassador bunker provided an
overview we are he said engaged in
fighting a limited war for limited
objectives and with limited resources at
the same time were advising and
supporting the vet leaves and their
efforts to carry out to carry through a
social revolution week after week and
month after month Abrams sought to
educate his commanders our people people
he said our people have got to realize
what this war is about it isn't that you
lie around in your base camp waiting for
somebody to cite a division marching
down the road and then you sally forth
and take the division on this war is a
far more complex thing than that as he
told the visiting general we are it's
the people that's what both sides are
struggling for thus abrams on our side
instead of talking about offensive we've
got to put a lot of effort up there so
that pacification continues to march and
continues to consolidate that's the
nature of the beast
instead of toying around about whether
you ought to move another brigade of the
4th division something like that that's
not the real answer and another time
this war if you're really going to
understand it and really get with it he
runs it the enemy runs it at about five
or six levels the levels or his
infrastructure guerilla structure local
force structure main force structure his
political effort is
propaganda effort in order to play in
that game effectively you've got to
operate at all those levels yourself
emphasizing the need to work against the
entirety of the enemy system abrams told
his commanders this what we've been
doing is sort of on a treadmill we have
focused on these main units and they're
always getting ready to hit saigon or
teen in whatever it is banned me to it
and so we go after that and we're
whacking them with b-52s intact air and
artery and dumping in on them and piling
on and that sort of thing and the
history of that is that we go ahead and
mash it all up but then he sends a lot
more guys down and builds it back up
again and we mash it all up again
and just you know caused a lot of
casualties and so on now the way to put
a stop to it he said the way to get off
the treadmill is to go after this other
part which always seems to survive this
is the way to run the war our war and
the other part was the enemy
infrastructure in the Hamlet's and
villages of rural Vietnam which through
coercion and terror was keeping the
rural populace under enemy domination in
the earlier period large-scale
operations primarily in the deep jungles
now were supplanted with large numbers
of small unit ambushes and sweeps and
these were recited so as to deny the
enemy access to the population so search
and hold operations Search and Destroy
operations were replaced by clear and
hold tactics these were designed to
protect the people those that I've
talked about that where the enemy was
had under domination and expanded
upgunned and better trained territorial
forces provided the hold in clear and
hold by early 1969 a senior commander
commented we have a lot of battalion
operations going on but when I say
battalion in many cases companies and
the companies are broken down in
platoons and so on but basically putting
out many works long-range reconnaissance
patrols or armed equivalents 30 from the
40th division 12 from 173rd Airborne
Brigade even Julian jewel widely known
for his devotion to body count would say
I'm perfectly willing to admit
Suffocation's my primary mission
ambassador you Alexis Johnson was then
assigned to the u.s. negotiating and
team in Paris when he visited Saigon
Abrams explained our forces are
fragmented in an awful lot of small
groups what we're trying to do here is
work against the machinery the machinery
of the enemy system the effort is to try
to have ambushes on every trail and
broken down and out there at night and
in the daytime and tries to work against
the system and he said modestly I think
it has increased his problems at a
commander's briefing it was stated that
the major thrust of a b-1 45 that was
the designator for the combined campaign
plan for 1970 combined meaning the
Vietnamese and the Americans had worked
it out together the briefer said it
places emphasis on assuring protection
of the Vietnamese people on pacification
and development and on improving the
combat effectiveness of the arvin F
meaning the Armed Forces of Vietnam the
principles he said of area security have
been incorporated the last reference to
area security meant the principles of
what was called the province study
that's short for a program for the
pacification and long term development
of Vietnam which was done this study was
done under general Harold K Johnson's
direction when he was army chief of
staff and then implemented by Abrams
when he took command in Vietnam that
study held in its central finding that
the critical actions are those that
occur at the village district and
provincial levels this is where the war
must be fought this is where the war and
the object which lies behind it must be
one in another commander's comforts in
August of 1970 general Abrams began like
this he'd like to use briefings as
springboards for discussion he says I
want to raise this with commanders I
think there are areas around here in
Vietnam right now where the question
should be asked whether artillery
gunships TAC air and all that
kind of stuff whether it ought to be
used at all his concern led to a study
that came to be called where do we let
peace come to Vietnam conduct of the
study was assigned to brilliant young
Air Force officer captain Barry Horton
general Lucius clay was then commanding
7th Air Force and he said to warden
general Abrams is really uncomfortable
that we are doing more harm than good on
another occasion speaking about the
problem of collateral damage as it was
euphemistically called Abrams said my
problem is colored blue blue being the
color on the battle maps usually desi
daily friendly forces red designating
the enemy my problem is colored blue we
have to rein in this this overuse of
firepower
captain Horton went away and he looked
at the conditions under which the
application of airpower produced
undesirable consequences and where that
could be unproductive and pretty soon
they expanded this study to look at our
Torrey as well I think it's a worthwhile
thing to go ahead and grapple with this
see what happens said Abrams what did
happen was quite remarkable Horton came
back and said he was running out of
instances to study the field commanders
had gotten the word and were
unilaterally cutting back on
disproportionate use of firepower in
populated areas two years into the
Abrams regime at a commanders conference
they featured a briefing entitled the
changing nature of the war the nature of
the conflict in South Vietnam has been
under changed since 10th of 1968 the
briefer said although shifts in the
level of violence type of military
operations and size and location of
forces involved are characteristics of
this change the Allied realization that
the war was basically a political
contest has thus far been decisive the
most significant development in this
shift of allied policy has been the
enemy's increasing loss of control over
the population very early on Abrams made
it clear that in such a conflict
conflict body-count was no longer the
primary measure of merit there's a lot
of evidence to go around he told his
nominal boss Admiral McCain there's
evidence to go around of a developing
disinterest in body count per se weapons
captured they're important to the field
commanders he said I don't think that
many makes any difference how many
losses he the enemy takes I don't think
that makes any difference then again to
the field commanders I know a body count
you know it has something about it but
it's really a long way from what's
involved in this war yeah you have to do
that I know that but the mistake is to
think that's the central issue and yet
again now I know the fighting is
important but all of these things in
pacification building the village in the
hamlet and really building a base and so
on I really think that of all the things
that's the most important that's where
the battle ultimately is won and finally
to a group of regional ambassadors
meeting in Saigon general Abrams comment
was in the whole picture of the war the
battles don't really mean much now have
a sidebar for you often in the course of
discussion to make a point on one topic
for another general Abrams would tell a
war story from earlier times or a Buster
buckler had a good blend of war stories
to sometimes Seville Kobe would would
weigh in on this too one time they were
discussing the difficulty of adaptation
to change and how hard it is to overcome
the way you've grown up and your own
experience and Abrams says you know
that's right it reminds me of my
regimental commander first regimental
commander I ever had and I was his
communications officer I had these four
pack radios on horses I had and I was
never allowed to be near the regimental
headquarters with them he was opposed
Terranea to radios and he used mounted
messengers for all of his communications
so one day we were out in the maneuver
and I was about ten miles back
they sent somebody back to get me and I
galloped up reported the regimental
commander and he said can you send a
message to the brigade commander I said
yes sir
he said all right send this message
compliments of Colonel her I have no
communications left send back my
messengers now that was that was a small
vignette from the days of horse cavalry
but but it had applicability to
adaptation and change I did not want to
make this presentation without telling
you something important about the
Vietnamese forces because after all they
were the they were the centerpiece of
the whole endeavor so trunk three has to
do with what they called regional forces
and popular forces when general Ravens
first arrived in Vietnam in May of 1967
he spent a year as the deputy before
taking command the Vietnamese forces
consisted of Army Navy Marine and Air
Force elements separate and apart were
what were called territorial forces
comprised of these regional forces and
popular forces and they answered to the
district chiefs in the province Chiefs
but in 1970 they had grown enormous Lee
now managed to some 550 thousand men and
they were integrated into the Regular
Force now they comprised just over half
that force as early as October 68
William Coley who was then newly
installed as everyone's deputy for
pacification support explained the
importance of these elements for
territorial securities that our main
focus is on improvement of the regional
and popular forces which are almost half
of the army now we started last October
general Abrams had a conference here
I've identified some thirty steps to
take including sending out small
advisory teams they now had 250 of these
five-man teams working around the
country
three months later Colby noted the rapid
buildup and improved training and
armament being provided the regional and
popular forces there are about 90 1,000
more of them today than there were a
year ago and a hundred thousand now have
m16s that was the quintessential rifle
for use in Vietnam which they didn't
have a year ago soon after Abrams had
taken command he had deliberately
channeled the new rifles to these
elements the RF and PFA year ago he said
in August 1969 received the highest
priority of anybody that's where the
first m16s went before Ireland in other
words before the Regular Army they've
been given he said for over a year the
highest priority
and to be frie perfectly frank it's like
anything else I mean you put your money
in soldiers deposits savings program you
get ten percent interest and so on damn
it he said we made an investment here
and there ought to be a payoff
and so the RF + PF began to do some
things and Abrams wanted to see them get
credit for the things they were doing
one thing I've been chafing under he
said at one of the weekly meetings is
when we briefed visitors the role of the
regional popular forces is substantially
submerged there's a tendency to talk
about the Ireland the Regular Army and
for some time now the RF + PF have borne
the brunt of casualties and this sort of
thing and the toll they're exacting from
the enemy is substantial I mean if you
just want to deal in that sort of thing
but if we get talking about the security
of the people this is a big part of this
whole thing this is where it is at the
end of 1969 general herbalist was
contemplating a chart displaying the
trend in what's happened in the last
three or four months in who's making a
contribution and he found that the arvin
contribution stayed about the same the
US and free world forces contributions
gone down because we're redeploying
forces and they're fewer of them and
percentage-wise the slack had been taken
up by territory forces and he said and
this has happened since August someone
remarked it's the nature of the war
Abrams responded yes that's right but
it's also I've been wondering what the
hell would we get for that investment in
those 300,000 m16s you know well it's
commencing to show and then later
they're talking about territorial forces
and Abrams says territorial forces these
rabbits are coming along good I have
another sidebar for you this one has to
do with the weather as anyone knows who
has served in Vietnam extremes of
weather they are almost the norm the
weather briefers let off every weekly
conference and often the news was not
good
by and large abrams once remarked the
fellow covering that thing first on
saturday his pitch has always been about
the same the roads are drying out pretty
good surface
enemy is bypassing our Road cuts it
always kind of irritated me said Evers
because he seems so happy about it the
enemy is doing good and so on but Abrams
was keenly aware of the weather's impact
and he pressed them to go deeper into
the realities of it so they could plan
better weather spectaculars were common
in october 1968 the briefer reported
that for the past week we forecast 1 to
2 inches of rain in I Corps and got 36
and 67 hundredths inches the maximum
ever reported rainfall ever reported at
Danang for the month of october was 49
inches he said and we're already well
over that in October of the next year
general wheeler was Britt was visiting
they had some rainfall yesterday up in I
Corps Abrams told him 'we got 14 and a
half inches a new all-time record and at
dawn how they got 7.2 inches Wheeler's
response practically a drought at dawn
haas even so that was next to nothing
compared to way through by at the same
season during the first nine days of the
month reported the briefer rainfall
their total 59 inches greater than any
monthly total ever recorded over the
past 30 years at any station in Vietnam
on one day alone one day along 22 inches
of rain fell during the 24 hour period
by the end of the month wave flew by
wound up with 75 point zero six inches
of rain and said the briefer it didn't
rain at all on 14 days of the month on
one Saturday morning about three days
into general Abrams service as commander
the weather briefer gave a detailed
description of the monsoon seasons and
their effects at the conclusion abram
says I want to thank you for very good
presentation he said on all the time
I've been here I've never heard this
explained in such depth
I guess he said you finally decided to
take us into your confidence I've been
talking about these weekly sessions that
they had in chunk four has to do with
with those and they called them the wood
W ie you weekly Intelligence Estimate
update pronounced whoo
typically these sessions took place at
McVie on Saturday mornings with general
Abrams and his senior associates on the
back feed staff as the participants
usually ambassador bunker would also
attend and sometimes deputy ambassador
burger while he does not appear on the
list of attendees which are found in
some of the tape boxes sometimes CIA
chief of station Saigon Ted Shackley was
also there then once a month the senior
field commanders from around the country
joined in and such sessions were then
called commanders Woo's besides that
high-level visitors often attended
people such as Admiral John McCain from
sink PAC and chairman of Joint Chiefs of
Staff General Earl wheeler
during his tenure general Abrams
continually pressed for the agenda of
these meetings to be broadened to
include much more than just military
aspects of the war and of course more
than just an intelligence update thus
the name will became more and more of an
anachronism in addition to the usual
agenda as Abrams once told a visitor we
try to generally generally have one or
two things that have been done in depth
over a period of time trying to
challenge what we think these were the
briefings that use the springboards for
discussion they were viewed by most
participants as the best parts of the
room
second only to what some called Abrams
eruptions on one occasion after such a
briefing had sparked debate and
discussion had gone on for 20 minutes or
so the briefer provoked uproarious
laughter by interjecting sir if I might
just add one comment the de facto master
of ceremonies for the Wu was the Mak VJ
to General William II Potts he was
serious about his job officers who
served with him can remember the
punctilious Potts sitting with a stack
of papers in front of him compulsively
police straightening them side to side
and top to bottom over and over again
and they remember Potts
with a small small notebook of
particularly sensitive information that
he consulted guardedly close to his
chest
much like WC Fields taking a peek at his
cards during a high-stakes poker game
after in one meeting when the last
battalion size attack had taken place
Potts
responded without an instant's
hesitation you've had eleven since the
1st of July 1 this past week was
reported as beside sized but after the
reports all got in it was company size
that was vintage pots as was another
occasion when general Abrams wondered
what it would look like if certain data
were displayed in graphic rather than
tabular form instantly Potts said put up
back up slide 5 and there it was as
though by magic shown the other way even
Abraham's was impressed at 1 grew the
matter of intelligence reports on
suspected enemy tanks was raised I think
I have a report on that said Potts step
out please instantly a new briefer
appeared and gave a complete rundown on
the subject when abrams asked for a
comparison of enemy input and throughput
during his logistics offensive suspense
ease for the past two years Potts said
put up slide 206 please then to Abrams
we had this updated for you last night
indeed pops almost seemed capable of
reading Abraham's mind bill do they have
the began Abrams before it could finish
the sentence Potts inserted bargraph
Abrams yeah can they show that instantly
pots slide 201 please none of this was
accidental unhappy with the response
time on one occasion Potts gathered his
staffers from some guidance after the
session fortunately the man making the
tape had let it keep running so I heard
Potts say see when the coma sets the
commander has his briefings anything
he's heard for the last six months he'll
call for pots prescribed intensified
rehearsals with a slide list call for
209 he said see if it'll can go up
within two seconds you just have to
drill drill drill pus himself seemed to
have mastered every fact in detail of
the complex events confronting Mac V
when for example Abrams asked a question
about Chinese manufacturer of the t59
tank Potts responded with a detailed and
very well informed discussion of eight
models of the t54 the last being
designated the t-55 and the Chinese
version or copy the T 15
only one of which he said has been
spotted so far after each briefing pots
conducted a careful personal critique
with his major subordinates at the same
time ensuring that they understood
whatever future tasking had resulted
from the session he was in this role
invariably courteous patient even school
masterly and gracious in publicly giving
credit to his intelligence analyst for
work well done not surprisingly a broom
stole pots that he was going to be the
max vj2 for as long as Abrams continued
in command and so he was out lasting in
the process 5 McPhee chiefs of staff
7j 3s and 6j fours now the last chunk
has to do with general Abrams himself
and I'll be brief here but I just like
to say a few things specifically about
him you could say I suppose that this is
my third Abrams book falling on
Thunderbolt a biography and a better
work the history of the years of his
command in Vietnam during the years
under Abrams as you know US forces were
progressively and inexorably withdrawn
from Vietnam as units departed for home
Abrams would go to visit them to say
goodbye and to thank them for their
service to the 1st Infantry Division's
for example he said in a changing world
changing times and changing attitudes
and the various political motivations
that have thrust themselves upon our
country the 1st Infantry Division
represents a Constance of those
essential virtues of mankind humility
courage devotion and sacrifice the world
has changed a lot he said but this
division continues to serve as it had in
the beginning I choose to feel that this
is part of the cement and the rock and
the steel that holds our great country
together and then he closed by quoting
back to them their own great division
motto no mission too difficult no
sacrifice too great
duty first those virtues defined not
only Creighton Abrams professional
ideals but his own service and example
he was in his own person the continuity
of leadership and purpose and vision for
our first forces in Vietnam and also the
cement and the rock and the steel that
held them together particularly was this
so in the difficult final years when
domestic support for the war had badly
eroded troops coming to Vietnam brought
with them attitudes and outlooks
conditioned by festering division and
dissent at home and the resources
available for prosecuting the war
continued to diminish through it all
Abrams maintained determination a sense
of purpose faith in the Worth and
validity of the mission and despite his
well known volatility a kind of serenity
late in this long service in Vietnam
general Abrams observed to the staff
that some of the days are kind of long
but the years go by very quickly I find
that a surpassingly poignant comment on
one of his last nights at McVie he spoke
to his closest associates at a dinner in
the command mess the longer he I serve
he told him the more I could become
convinced that the single most important
attribute of the professional officers
is integrity the final tape in the
collection is the last word during
general Abrams tenure as Comus McPhee
and the last segment of that tape
consists of remarks by ambassador
Ellsworth bunker saying goodbye to
Abrams and thanking him for their five
years of shared service those years were
he said the most rewarding of a fairly
long career that began with a horse
artery in 1916 certainly bunker said
speaking now directly to Abrams
certainly the Armed Forces of the united
states have shown determination and will
and steadiness in a most difficult
situation I think it's clear it's
certainly clear to me that out with
without your leadership and without what
your colleagues have done here
there wouldn't be any Republic of
Vietnam today and this has been done to
your leadership to not only highest
intelligence and professional skill but
to sensitivity effectiveness with what
the Yankees call plain common sense and
finally and I think you know I don't
have to tell you that you leave with not
only the great of admiration but the
greatest affection of us all
to that general evren's responded
characteristically Thank You mr.
ambassador gentlemen let's go to lunch
that ends the last tape in the
collection and also my remarks thank you
very much thoroughly for the viewing
audience at home I would like to welcome
you to the National Archives we have
gathered here in the William G McGowan
theatre to hear dr. Lewis Sorel as he
will just as he's discussed his book the
Abrams tapes 1968 to 1972 we do have
time for questions from the audience for
those of you who may not be able hear I
will repeat the question so how about we
open up the floor
yes sir general labels criticisms of the
press he shared a view with virtually
everyone that is heard on the tapes that
the accounts rendered were not
representative of what was being done I
think it was in many cases more of a
criticism of omission rather than pursue
some of what was written for example as
you heard me quote as far as general
Abrams was concerned the battles were
not the most important part of the war
by any means and yet the other aspects
the worst seldom got written about
seldom got reported they even have in
their accounts where someone will talk
about a correspondent with whom they've
discussed this matter and the
correspondent is shouting material that
he sent in and then it hasn't gotten
through the editorial process or made it
onto the error into the papers and so on
so I think and I've written elsewhere
and I think this is a view I derive from
my study of general Abrams let the press
basically least in his latter years
missed the war because they didn't
either
understander didn't care about these
other parts of the war that abrams
continued to emphasize so much yes sir
thank you
while researching my book America and
Vietnam I interviewed several members of
January with the staff and one of them
told me that while Abrams had a lot of
new and important innovative ideas and
plans he found it difficult to get these
plans implemented because many of his
commanders preferred to go on the old
and disproven way of conducting
search-and-destroy operations could you
comment on that I'd be glad to comment
on that there is no doubt that
everyone's had to persuade his senior
subordinate commanders that his
understanding of the nature of the war
and how it ought to be conducted was was
the correct way I mentioned a general
Julia Newell before when the first
briefing was given this is on the tapes
when the first briefing was given about
the so called area security concept
general Ewell was not favorably
impressed at all but then I quoted him
only a few months later is saying he's
perfectly willing to admit the
pacification in his number-one job and
and this is what everyone said
ambassador Charlie White House told me
once that general Abrams was up and down
the country week after week month after
my preaching his his understanding of
the nature of the war and how it should
to be conducted and it's quite clear
that he was more successful in some
cases than others he come back he comes
back one day from a visit to the fourth
every division and it's not at all happy
with it with the operations that they've
briefed him on it's more big battalion
things out near that near the border you
know in the deep jungle and and they
want they said well they've just been
out thrashing around they only got five
enemy in about a week's operation he
said they they think it's because they
didn't have a good enough intelligence
well he thinks it's because they don't
understand the nature of the war so so
he and general Abrams is in fact is the
not only the continuity but the
institutional memory because most of the
senior commanders who worked for him
even the general officers only stayed
maybe a year and a half or two years
he's there for five straight years
the commander's at lower levels come and
go in a one-year time so he and I've
concluded a some material in the in the
book that one might do is repetitious to
show that he had to keep making these
same points over and over again so you
know there is a degree to which the
comment you received is in fact accurate
I had three tours in Vietnam the last
two of which were during general Abrams
tenure covered by your book and it's so
refreshing to hear these words I used to
sit in as one of his subordinate
commanders on the monthly booze and it's
really refreshing I compliment you on
capturing this wonderful story of
general Abrams I'm gonna buy the book
but I wanna tell you I already have each
shoots and leaves but you're gonna miss
that on the package deal then I I I took
a copy of the book to general andrew
Goodpasture who during general Abrams
first year was his deputy he had three
deputies one the first year one the
second year and then another for the
last two years and and I showed a couple
of passages to general Goodpaster that
I'd marked it for his attention and his
response was very to me was very
gratifying he said all this is so real
this is so real and it is there is no
spin on this material the only thing
I've added is enough little signposts to
help you find your way through the
period of time but it is the people so
they're saying what they thought and
believed at the time and they're not
performing this is you know they're
sitting around the table trying to fight
the world
the general Abrams at any time after he
had completed the service there find
receptive people in the Congress that he
could talk to or that they requested to
get information from him as I alluded to
it's a good question as I alluded to
general Abrams came back to be chief of
staff and only two years into what would
normally been a four-year tour he died a
great loss to the army but the the
tributes to him when he died were very
dramatic and very interesting and many
of them came from the Congress he was
considered a very credible witness
earlier when he had been the vice chief
of staff he went over to testify on the
Army's budget and there were lots of
issues on the eye on the agenda and so
they got to one the question about
whether the army needed a new handgun to
replace the Calgary 45 pistol and
General Avery was dismissed that in one
sentence he said well he said it all
depends on the circumstances in a
crowded elevator there's no finer weapon
and and then the transcript shows
brackets laughter close brackets they
move on but but after his death one
member of Congress I'm sorry to say I
don't have this person's name in my head
but he said general Abrams voice in his
testimony before the concrete Congress
was very refreshing it was a quiet voice
it was a modest voice it was an honest
voice and and I think he did have great
credibility what he tried to do of
course during the limited time that he
had as army chief of staff was to put
the army back on his feet and plot its
course for the depth for the years ahead
the army is we all know had suffered
greatly from that long inconclusive
experience general Abrams focused on two
things as chief of staff combat
readiness and care of the soldier he had
some saints that he liked very much and
a lot of them had to do with his
soldiers one of them one of them was
people are not in the army people are
the army and then often he would say
soldiering is an affair of the heart and
so he he focused on those things and
even though he died after only two years
he had some dedicated subordinates who
carried
with the plans and and the programs and
the vision that he had set forth and and
later General Jack Vesey who became the
chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
wrote that when people saw the forces
that fought in Desert Storm they were
seeing the Abrams vision in action
he said the equipment that worked the
use of reserve forces the close air
support and above all he said the great
training that taught our soldiers how to
stay alive on the battlefield those were
all seeds planted by April if by the
summer of 1968 pacification had taken
its rightful place in the prosecution of
the war why the criticism so much of
ambassador comer was one based more on
policy and personality than policy comer
was hard to like comer had been there
about a week when they had a somebody
invited a bunch of people over for a
Sunday afternoon cookout which included
the game of water polo in the swimming
pool and one fellow wrote home and said
that they'd played this water polo but
mostly it was a game of get comer that's
only he'd only been there a week so and
he'd already you know engendered this
kind of a response
ambassador comer has complimented
himself at every opportunity for his
major contributions to the conduct of
the war my belief is that the
pacification program did not take off
until bill Colby developed what came to
be called the accelerated pacification
campaign which was implemented I believe
one November of 1968 by then comer gone
home and Colby had succeeded him
Colby Abrams and bunker were men of like
mind and like qualities they were they
were men of great character and decency
and modesty and they admired that in
others and I think comer just didn't fit
in yes sir
could you provide a little more detail
for people listening about the different
the
specifically what pastor you mean by
pacification and how that contrasts with
other policies yes thank you I will the
pacification program that we've been
talking about in which Abrams was so
strong on emphasizing had to do with a
number of different things that all went
together in in talking about it if they
were briefing some visitors for example
George Jacobson was another man who had
a lot to do with this and Jacobson one
time got up in his briefing he said
people disagree about whether security
is ten percent of pacification or 90
percent of pacification but they all
agree that it's the first ten percent or
the first 90 percent he said you just
can't conduct pacification with an NVA
division in the backyard and so so the
first part of it is effective combat
operations and that means not thrashing
out the deep jungle but interposing your
forces between the people and the enemy
forces so they've got to come through
you to get to the people which is as you
heard me say the object of both sides of
the enterprise so that's that's the
first thing the second thing was to get
rid of this covert infrastructure that's
in the villages and hamlets and and as
using portion and terror to dominate the
the rural population and the way to do
that was intelligence and a program
you've heard of called Phoenix was the
way to build the intelligent network at
one time there were 17 different
intelligence enterprises their
operations of some kind of Vietnam aney
basically they weren't talking to one
another so a key thing is to integrate
that intelligence and make it available
on a timely basis and and so they began
to try to root out this infrastructure
that's another important part a third
really important part and al I've seen a
lot of people write wrongly about this
president tube was very interested in in
strengthening and reconstituting village
level government some people have said
he was against that it's this is
absolutely not the case the the senior
people there ambassador bunker and
general Abrams and Coby said the
president too is the number-one
pacification officer in this country he
more about it than any other Vietnamese
and he is giving it everything he's got
and they took a training center down at
a place called funk town which had been
used to trade a train what were called
revolutionary development Kadri and they
turned it into a training center for
Hamlet and village officials and they
would run them through a course there
and they'd teach them how to be village
and Hamlet fischels and president Hugh
went down and talked to every one of
those courses enabling the province not
not that the village chief to go home
and have the cachet of being able to say
well as president Chu said to me down at
funk out well and they could all say
that and they ran in one year they ran
some I don't have the exact number about
80% of all the hamlet and village
officials in Vietnam through this course
and there were two people there that
were key to their instruction one was
president you the other was Colonel
babyyyyy who was a brilliant man of
former viet minh who ran this school and
he said to them you live in a corrupt
society your job is to go back and make
it better and he said you are a little
president in your village or Hamlet and
he got to act like one and and the
reason you're there is to make things
better for the people well this is you
know I earlier on I I quoted somebody
saying that I think was ambassador
Walker we're helping them through a
social revolution well this was a part
of that
so now pacification is all these things
together and just like Abram said you
have to work against the enemy system
and if you're not successful in dealing
with each element of the system you're
going to fail overall so did you have to
bring all these things together currency
reform was another really important part
land reform wasn't nearly it was another
very important part and all those work
together and and the pacification level
went up and up and up was it typical to
make tapes like this in these kind of
meetings and if not why did abrams have
them made good question and it will help
me state a research interest Barbara
thank you the proper the practice of
taping these weekly meetings was begun
before general Abrams came to Vietnam so
it started sometime during general
Westmoreland's tenure but with
don't know exactly when he also
commanded for four years so sometime in
that for years they began to do this now
the ones that I have had access to or of
course the ones that general Abrams took
part in beginning with his first wooh in
June of 68 and ending with the one I
quoted from at the end of June of 72
those all came home with him and were
sequestered as I said presumably there
are some from general Westmoreland's
tenure somewhere and I have exerted a
very great efforts to try to find those
because they'd be equally interesting
from that period and I'm not writing a
biography of general Westmoreland I
would certainly like to have access to
those materials so far all the people
who would be expected to have custody of
them say they do not have any such
materials and I can't gain say that so
but I'm hoping that they may still turn
off it's hard for me to believe that
anyone would destroy such obviously
valuable materials so I'm hoping they'll
turn up apart from those two examples
though I don't know of any other cases
where this kind of thing has been done
you know on a linear basis so over time
we've got the story as it evolves some
of the things that are in here are
invaluable because we it's been asserted
that certain enemy offensives were not
anticipated ha not so in Easter
offensive o-72 they're talking about in
January the truck got in February
they've got fixes on all the enemy units
as they move south and they're ready for
them when they come that kind of thing a
lot of work a lot of things now are done
by email a lot of things are done on
secure voice phone when I was writing
the Abrams biography Thunderbolt
Business Abrams very kindly allowed me
to see the letters her husband had
written to her during World War 2 in
Korea and they were wonderful material
unfortunately he didn't write her any
letters from Vietnam because she lived
in Bangkok and he had a hotline and they
talked on the phone every day so that's
all lost so I think in many ways as I
suggest the beginning this is absolutely
unique because we never had anything
like this before
and I don't know that we will ever have
it again lady Jang run round of applause
for dr. sorely
before we lowest early is a West Point
graduate who served in a tank battalion
in Vietnam he's authored several books
about that conflict his latest Vietnam
Chronicles is published by Texas Tech
University Press